truth is not what you want it to be
it is what it is
and you must Bend to its power or live a
lie
you must understand that there is more
than one path to the top of the mountain
to win any battle
you must fight as if you are already
dead
it may seem difficult at first
but everything is difficult at first
do not regret what you have done
to know ten thousand things
no one will
if you do not control the enemy
the enemy will control you
fixation is the way to death
fluidity is the way to life
do nothing
that is of no use
the only reason a warrior is alive is to
fight
and the only reason a warrior fights is
to win
perceive that which cannot be seen with
the eye
today is victory over yourself of
yesterday
tomorrow is your victory over lesser men
do not waste time idling or thinking
after you have set your goals
one thousand days of lessons for
discipline
Ten Thousand Days of lessons for Mastery
there is more to life than increasing
its speed
the ultimate aim of martial arts is not
having to use them
you can only fight the way you practice
understand the harm and benefit of
everything
with your spirit open and unconstricted
look at things from a high point of view
it is difficult to understand the
universe if you only study one planet
true Warriors are fierce
because their training is fierce
in battle
if you make your opponent flinch
you have already won
step by step
walk the Thousand Mile Road
do not let the body be dragged Along by
mind nor be dragged Along by the body
the path that leads to truth is littered
with bodies of the ignorant
in time all things work to your
advantage when you pursue them with an
open heart
if you know the way broadly you will see
it in everything
can collapse
houses bodies and enemies collapse
when their Rhythm becomes deranged
resentment and complaint are appropriate
neither for oneself or others
foreign
if there isn't discipline How can there
be a true realization of an ideal
generally speaking
the way of the warrior is Resolute
acceptance of death
in life you need to have no fear
no hesitation
no surprise
No Doubt
if the enemy thinks of the mountains
attack like the sea
and if he thinks of the sea
attack like the mountains
those who can't be alone can't be honest
can't be loyal
can't be anything
you may abandon your own body
but you must preserve your honor
to make anyone immediately regret
insulting you
show that you are unaffected
the purpose of today's training is to
defeat yesterday's understanding
whatever your determination or willpower
it is foolish to try to change the
nature of things
things work the way they do because that
is the way of things
think lightly of yourself
and deeply of the world
we have collected these quotes by one of
the best known Japanese Swordsmen
Miyamoto Musashi Not only was Musashi an
excellent swordsman he was also a writer
and philosopher his thoughts were
collected in this video for you to enjoy
thank you for watching